there was a report about
uh perhaps a radio signal detected from
proxima
centauri what do you make of that signal
oh i think it's some australian guy with
a cell phone next to the observatory or
something like that
because it was the parks telescope in
australia
okay i was like yeah okay so it's no
human
created noise yeah which is always the
worry
because actually the same observatory
the parks observatory
detected a couple of years ago some
signal and then they realized
that it comes back at lunch lunchtime
yes and they said okay what could it be
and then they figured out that it must
be the microwave oven in the observatory
because someone was opening it
before it finished and it was creating
this radio signal
that they detected with the telescope
every lunch time
uh so just a cautionary remark
but the reason i think it's human-made
without getting to the technical details
is because
of this very short window by which we
were transmitting radio signals out of
the lifetime of the earth
you know as i said 100 years out of four
and a half
billion years that the earth existed so
what's the chance that another
civilization a twin civilization of ours
is transmitting radio signals exactly at
the time that we are looking
with our radio telescopes yeah ten to
the minus seven you know
so and the other the other argument i
have that is
uh is that they detected it in a very
narrow band of frequencies and that
makes it
i'm not you know it cannot be through
natural processes very narrow band
just like some radio transmissions that
we produce
but if it were to come from the
habitable zone from a transmitter on the
surface of proxima b
this is the planet that orbits proxima
centauri
then i calculated that the frequency
would drift
through the doppler effect you know just
like when you hear a siren
on the street you know when the car
approaches you it has a different
pitch than when it goes recedes away
from you that's the doppler effect
and when the planet orbits the star
proxima centauri
you would see or detect a different
frequency when the planet approaches us
as compared to when it resists so
there should be a frequency drift just
because of the motion
of the planet and i calculated that it
it it must be much bigger than then
observed so it cannot just be a
transmitter sitting on the planet
and sending another direction a radio
signal unless they want
to cancel the doppler effect but then
they need to know about
us because in a different direction it
will not be canceled only in our
direction
they can cancel it perfectly so
there is this direction of proxima
centauri but
i have a problem imagining a transmitter
on the surface
of a planet in the habitable zone
emitting it
but my main issue is really with a
likelihood
given what we know about ourselves right
in terms of the durations the
civilization the copernican principle
yeah
you